no individual motorcades but coaches to
ferry even the world's princes and
presidents ensuring arrivals ran like
clockwork
the emperor and empress of japan for
whom funeral appearances are rare
because of their shinto faith shared a
bus with the king and queen of bhutan
a photo opportunity for kenya's
president smiling widely at the back of
the picture but after intensive
negotiations there were only a handful
of exceptions to the travel arrangements
america's president joe biden arrived in
his cadillac dubbed the beast for
security reasons
and china's vice president also came by
car an indication of the diplomatic
tightrope walked by the foreign office
has there ever been a world event where
such thought must have gone into the
seating arrangements of so many foreign
dignitaries and royal families coming to
pay their respects to the queen
canada's justin trudeau first met the
queen as a child when his father was
prime minister
joe biden one of 14 u.s presidents
during the queen's reign described her
as a state's woman of unmatched dignity
but in the service the special place the
queen held for the commonwealth was
clear with the first lesson read by
baroness scotland
when he shall have put down all rule
and all authority
and power
new zealand's prime minister jacinda
ardern who gave birth while in office
said the queen once advised her on
juggling roles you just have to get on
with it
it is those personal anecdotes those
international relationships which
fostered such admiration for the queen
leaving westminster abbey the rare sight
of royalty waiting for a bus and forming
a cue
but a sign of the global reverence
commanded by queen elizabeth ii amongst
the world leaders who came together to
lay her to rest
lisa holland sky news